Let's take a look at the code in
the UIViewController (Record) category
in the Objective C project.
To create this ActionSheet,
first we'll need to rewrite the method
presentVideoOptions.Then we need to
connect that method to the record button
instead of launch a video camera.
So let's switch back to
the swift project and
rewrite this method in our
uIviewController swift extension.
Okay, here we are back in
the swift version of GIF maker.
In our UIViewController swift extension.
We've created the function
presentVideoOptions and
first we need to check if
the camera's available.
If the camera's not available,
we want to launch the photo library
which we'll just put in comments for
now.
If the camera is available we create an
action sheet of type UIAlertController.
Next, we need to create three
actions to add to the ActionSheet.
Here's the first one, recordVideo.
It'll have the default style and
the completion handler will call
the method launchVideoCamera.
Here's the second action,
chooseFromExisting.
It also has the default style and
this action will call the method
launchPhotoLibrary, which again,
we'll just put in comments for now.
The third action is cancel.
There's a designated style for
cancel, and
we can leave the completion handler nil.
Then we add each of the three
actions to the ActionSheet.
Finally, we present the ActionSheet and
set the tint color of
the titles to pink.
In the end, the ActionSheet
will look something like this.